Alright,
so you're always in one of these little
frameworks and there's just no getting
out of it.
So,
and that's because you know,
at any given moment this is like,
it's like field theory.
There used to be psychological theories
that talked about the field of human
experience,
something like that.
And this is kind of what that is.
This is a field and basically what
happens is you parse out a little part
of the world say and so an amount you
can handle.
So let's say it has some duration.
You're not aiming at something 50 years
in the future.
It's because how the hell are you going
to do that?
There's too many variables,
you know,
so you're aiming at some handleable
amount of time and you,
it a goal in there and you plot your
route and then that tells you what's up
and tells you what's down.
[inaudible]
moves you towards the goal and down
moves you away from the goal and that
sets up your motivational framework so
that you have some worth attaining.
You know,
that's a really interesting thing to
know too.
It's like why have a goal ball?
It's easy,
no goal,
no positive emotion because you
experienced positive emotion by noticing
that you're moving towards a goal and so
if you don't have to have a goal while
you can't have any positive emotion,
so better have a goal,
and so you might say,
well,
what should the goal be?
Well,
we could start by saying,
well,
any goal is better than none,
and then we might say,
well,
it should be a goal that other people
will let you pursue because otherwise
it's going to be kind of difficult and
maybe there'll be even happy to help you
pursue it.
That would even be better and maybe it's
a goal that would enable you to learn
how to pursue other goals while you
pursue that goal.
Boy,
that would really be good,
and so you can see that your goal is
parameterized,
but that doesn't mean that any old goal
works.
It means there's some goals that were
nicely and some not so nicely.
There are playable games and no
unplayable games.
That's a good way of thinking about it
and you want to have a playable game and
there's a lot of them.
Lawyer,
plumber,
you know,
actor,
whatever,
they're,
they're playable games and,
and it's not obvious which ones better,
but it's certainly obvious which ones
are sustainable and which ones are worse
and so there's a set of playable games
and you need to extract from that set of
playable games,
a game that suits you and that would be
partly due to your temperament,
you know,
because extroverted people want to play
an extroverted game and highly neurotic
people want to play a safe game and
agreeable people want to play a generous
game and disagreeable people wanting to
play a game that's highly competitive so
they can win and you know,
fine,
but they're all within the realm of
playable games and that means they're
socially acceptable as well.
And so that means it isn't just
arbitrary,
it isn't just relative what you decide
to do.
It's heavily parameterized.
There's only,
there's a set of playable games and it's
large.
The set is large,
but it,
there are commonalities within it.
And that's why there are commonalities.
That's why morality has a common basis
fundamentally.
And so that's partly what we're trying
to investigate is like,
what's up?
What does that mean?
What does it mean?
Is there such a thing?
Now,
one thing to remember is that if you
don't direct a hierarchical structure
with a someday,
Matt,
you got no positive motivation because
you experience positive motivation in
relationship to a goal,
not from attaining the goal,
that satisfaction,
and besides it's fleeting,
you know perfectly well,
you graduate from university,
Poof,
next day you have a problem,
which is what do you do next?
And that's a,
that's a tough problem.
It's not like you've solved your
problems by winning that game,
you just introduced the problem of
having to introduce another game.
So it's unreliable as a source of
positive emotion.
But what's reliable is you set a goal
and you try to attain it.
And then that gives your life that
literally provides your life with
meaning.
That's what meaning is.
Now it's more than that,
but that's what it is.
And so then you might ask yourself,
well,
what's a really good goal?
Well,
that's what we're trying to figure out.
What's a really good goal.